Well go to your mom's house,
Christina,
it's
you.
But to put this down,
John,
I try
to slip in
here.
Eric
is I
glass
sand my arrow into flight.
I got a really bad bike.
You'd have a super moves.
Go down.
[inaudible] what's your name about that boy?
The head.
I'm a self trained punch.
Honestly with my dad.
Some smell of his peers.
A sentiments as a few loads of come cause you know that I'm bad.
I ain't got no tail.
Put that bug in my ass.
It just like the gays.
What do you remember your dad?
You got to be coming as the symbol pub.
Does a good mom to Thomas in the crevice of you per se.
But again,
budget.
Do you know how much money my smile is?
I've got a really bad,
bad,
got a really bad light.
Calming does take.
Just slip it alone.
This
big huge mass glass and now here Eric de
[inaudible]
ride on his ass and beat.
You heard this is how I you did.
Can you just to the tune,
I'm going to drink
this please shower.
Get away from DPH.
You Shit.
That's glass,
glass,
glass.
Slash the most.
There you go.
That is of all the songs we played on this show,
I would say that is one of the most beloved people have just been tweeting and
emailing about it.
I absolutely loved the closing song,
young past episode.
How eyeglass produced by chef.
Um,
that was uh,
yeah,
I mean I got so many messages,
particularly get them,
uh,
you know,
a lot of songs,
but my goodness,
that closed out in the last episode,
I think three 82 and uh,
I keep getting messages about it.
Yeah.
It's really,
and that's,
that's rare.
Just like a double pipe classic.
Yeah.
Way to go young.
Patriotic.
Thank you for doing so.
That's glass.
Let's glass tilted
to camera.
Yeah,
it looks tilted.
It's tilted right?
It looks a little.
Yeah.
Let me see.
Hold on.
That's weird.
But the framing looks
it's not leaning.
Alright.
Right.
Like when you look down at it,
I guess I can't really tell.
It's tilted down.
Okay.
All right.
Now and I tilted down.
Alright.
Um,
quick listen to this for all my audio files here.
so you remember like a month ago when the computer took a shit man and it turns
out like I,
it showed no output.
There was um,
that's all good to apple.
I had to replace a logic board.
Yeah.
I just went to a sec cause I worked with two computers now.
Same thing.
No output again.
So weird.
Yeah.
And I had it plugged in and it was just doing like some crazy noise like no.
Oh boy.
So I think the logic board is shot again,
but I don't understand how that's happening.
I don't know.
You have bad luck with technology.
Yeah.
But I mean all I did was just plug into it.
So yeah.
I don't know dude.
You know what?
My speaker on my,
my phone is acting up.
I can't hear as well.
That'd be getting older.
I like it really loud.
My phone.
You're like,
I,
I don't even know what,
what you're saying right now.
Tell you I am getting older.
I feel as though there's like,
by the end of the day I can't compute what you're saying to me.
Like yesterday.
You are trying to explain to me about keys and the door and which keys go in
there.
And I was like,
Babe,
save it for tomorrow.
Yeah.
You give up at a certain point.
I think by eight 40 I'm in.
I'm in my jammer.
No,
by eight o'clock I'm in my pajamas.
Yeah.
Hey,
excuse me.
And then nine o'clock it's lights out.
You schnitzel.
Excuse me.
By the way,
Schnitzel weighs about 10 pounds more than she did,
but before we moved here.
Enormous.
Why she's so big.
It's like,
it's that is the heat on in here?
No,
it's not right.
No.
Okay,
good.
It feels warm.
Well,
I know today it's hot out.
Yeah,
I'm in a while.
Yeah.
Hashtag Betsey's fat Hashtag [inaudible] what are they seeing?
They're,
they're freaking out.
Who knows?
Jesus,
nothing as usual.
They're reflections.
Hold on one second.
What you doing?
She Nitze come here.
Fatty.
Come here.
Let's see how fat you are.
Come here,
baby.
Fitzy come here.
Come here.
Look fucking fat.
She is,
she's huge.
She's,
we're not,
we're not assholes.
Just kind of look your Straw for sure.
Uh,
it's that it's the cause of the baby.
It's because of maybe some of,
we were looking through pictures this morning and back in October,
bitsy was like in the background of one of the pictures with Lj and she was
significantly thinner.
And what's happening is she's eating all of ljs food.
When he drops or whatever,
he,
they checked for the tropics builds over.
She is the vacuum cleaner.
We've got to keep her out of the kitchen.
I don't know.
But see,
here's the problem is that I'm lazy and I like that we don't have to clean up
the floor.
Naw,
Babe.
Why natures?
They're nature's cleaners.
That's why you get dog,
so you don't have to clean the floor out of your toddler's she's wound.
He was like a little bird dog.
She should bird on four legs.
It's just like stilts.
Well,
cause usually you're like,
we're the only people that have a 30 pound Brussels.
She's too big.
We got how much should she way Max?
50 dozen.
What third?
No,
what do you think?
She actually weighs probably like 18 or something.
She's alone and she's a sturdy dog.
Like they're not,
they're not weak little dogs,
Brussels.
But she's definitely,
we got to curb it.
She's struggling to jump on the couch.
She does.
Like it looks like she has an OCB cause she takes like five shots at it before
she does it right now.
T three can't get up.
No,
I try.
I can't.
Well here's what I'm going to do because I'm not going to stop her eating the
table scraps cause I,
where are we going to lock them out of the kitchen then they're going to go shit
all over the house.
You know how they are.
So I think what I'm going to have to do is like half her dry food.
Yeah.
Just half that so that she can just eat the scraps.
You know,
what are we going to do?
And I don't want to clean the floors.
Do you know?
Of course.
So this is the obvious solution.
Cut back the kibble.
Let her eat people's food.
It's not a bad,
it's not a bad solution.
Um,
how has fif not fatter though?
Because he eats the same shit.
It's usually quick on the draw.
He goes,
but I think she's beating him all the time.
I think she's,
because she's a little more savvy about food consumption.
She sits right under his high chair,
like right there.
And then FIFA is kind of off to the side a little.
He chills.
Yeah.
They're always looking like right now they're looking for crumbs.
I don't know what's going on.
Should we do a proper show open?
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
I forgot it.
Let's do it.
Here we go.
Just like the gays
ladies.
I want to do a video about this fucking lady
gars our water.
Christina,
I don't know.
Don't ask me.
I just looked really annoying.
The uh,
that this one just stop or is when all the audio is like,
this is the,
the treasure chest of audience.
This is all the original,
everything.
Right.
And I just had the logic board replace before that issue and now it's fucked
again.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
Do you think it is,
and this is so stupid and this is such like a person who doesn't know about
technology and saying something,
so don't get mad at me.
I'm not mad at you.
Do you think it's plugging in and plugging out a lot?
Like the sound Kiki's we've,
we're always plugging and unplugging.
Like do you think be the constant polling of,
of a thing in and out of the port hole or whatever it is.
It,
I don't think that should cause a problem,
but yes,
I think that's part of where is something down.
Maybe over time.
I know.
I Dunno.
But here cute though.
I love you.
Thank you.
I love you too.
Very handsome man.
Uh,
thank you.
Thank you.
It's Valentine's Day.
It is.
As we record this,
talked to my dad today.
He goes,
buddy,
that's your mom cars in a flower.
Well yeah.
He goes,
yeah,
she tells me not to,
but it's like you something [inaudible] and Lan ladies say,
don't worry,
I'll get me anything.
They don't mean it.
They don't,
they generally don't.
It's absolute truth but eyes.
But he's also been saying that to me for like 30 years.
But your mom is the type that she actually secretly wants stuff.
Of course she won't ever be like,
don't get me anything this year.
I'm telling you,
I got nothing.
I got nothing to so you can be upset with me.
I'm not upset.
I have,
I've done nothing for you.
Absolutely.
I listen.
I got you.
I got you a baby.
I got you baby.
That's the present.
That's it.
No,
I don't believe I,
you know,
I think you and I celebrate Valentine's Day all year long quite.
And I mean that quite honestly,
that I feel as though you and I have a good thing going.
Three 65 so it's one day that I just don't like being told what to do.
I don't like being told that we have to look
nothing.
Yeah.
I ate the pussy and always wanting us to love their calm,
to just love
licking it and how she bodies and swallowing it.
Who put guys are you dating?
So we're that.
She makes these videos,
guys,
card partner about their time.
She got it sounds like a muppet or something like sesame street now.
And here's the thing,
I other,
there's Beethoven and Mozart over Costco over her shoulders.
She's super culture,
urban culture versus talking about their car.
And so anyway,
she's got great teeth.
But the thing is,
and all the men that I've been with and had spent a lot,
so many Cox,
I don't know of any guys that have been like,
I want you to really enjoy my cup.
I need you to swallow it.
Love it.
Lap it up.
Let me put it like I dunno,
I dunno who this bitch is dating.
She's dating some real fucking animals.
Clear.
Yeah.
Like what kind of guy are you dating?
Only like what does it,
Tinder hookups.
She fucks a lot.
Somebody,
what did we find out the story with her?
Remember cause she got to her video,
we played her another clip she did where she was looking at I'm and
uh,
I think she was married and then got divorced and then went on a com CommScope
paid.
So now she's on like one of these apps probably just banging out.
Randos she's really jumping on those days,
man.
That same guy will never even touch his own commerce,
taste his own car.
Why would he seen this happen so many times?
It's so important.
Yeah,
it's a really important,
so board and the guys,
the guys are of waiting.
They're calm then that bothers you?
Or
do you avoid yours?
I mean,
I guess to a certain degree.
I don't know.
I don't avoid it.
No.
I mean I'm not repulsed by it,
but you know you want to clean it up,
right?
Yeah.
I'm not repulsed by it either.
It's not.
It's a non issue really going to taste it like she just like,
that's a problem for her.
I think guys are like,
oh no,
I don't want to taste it.
Yeah.
Well I guess her point is,
you know,
you want me to taste it?
That's a big deal.
Why don't you taste your com?
But not all guys want her to taste it.
She's just say she's in a different,
like a very specific wheelhouse right now.
She's meeting some guy just want to get it out of them and they don't care if it
tastes like,
just get it out.
I don't care if you taste it,
you know.
I mean,
why do you have,
you don't have to taste it.
I mean,
I know that some people,
that's their,
you know,
some guys who like to taste their own sure that too.
But I'm saying that would it where it would be an issue like this.
Yeah.
She,
she's making it big.
I'm rubbing it in and I swallow or add to all the stuff with it.
Same Guy.
If his head accidentally brushes against the kiss,
come on,
my body's like,
oh,
what's that?
Oh well then he's an asshole.
Like it was fucking really young guys.
That's good for you.
But I think he's fucking really young teenagers that are like,
yeah.
I'm like,
cause she's saying that that's kind of like a guy being like,
oh my comes gay.
Like touching your own count as gay.
Kind of sounds like it sounds very juvenile.
Does Donald,
she's fucking college guys.
So again,
salute.
But uh,
you know,
I don't think most like 40 year old guys are going to dump on her and be like,
Ooh,
I want to touch it at me.
I'm scared of it now.
I swallows come in and kiss him.
He's like,
no,
she's fucking young guys.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Does that,
does that the thing you don't think you care,
you don't care about anything,
nothing phases.
You had all your,
probably the least phaseable of all the dudes I've ever been,
which is probably why we're married because nothing phases you like I could
probably just take a shit on and around in and around your mouth.
Like Danny,
Danny,
and you'd be like,
Yep.
You just roll with it.
Yeah,
definitely.
I'm ready to go.
Ready to go?
Yeah.
Ready to go.
Karen fresh.
It's Trish now.
We haven't,
we haven't mentioned that on,
we mentioned that on the live show,
but not,
I guess we should park for a second.
Tell everybody holy shit.
Thank you for coming to the live show.
Oh my God.
Uh,
to,
to back to back podcasts in Irvine.
So fun.
Sold out A's in crowds.
Uh,
second one had Yoshi,
one of our all time hall of fame gusts,
Yoshi Obayashi and I'm not,
she'll got wild by the way.
That was such,
that might be our were filthy.
That might be our filthiest show ever between the content,
like the drops,
Yoshi,
having a microphone,
audience members,
wink,
wink.
It was a fucking disgust fest,
but it was really fun and it's Super Fun.
But I feel like they want it to go on that journey.
Of course it was like,
it was a mutual thing.
Whose House is it right to my mom's house.
Like,
yeah man,
do what we want.
It's fun.
It was really fun.
And just so that everybody knows,
people have asked both shows will be available for download.
Um,
I think the first we're going to do the early show you in a week or two and then
the late show will come out all week or two later and they won't,
they won't be in place of regular episodes.
They will be in addition to,
so yeah,
it's like a bonus.
So like your bonus,
it won't replace the regular no,
no,
no programming.
Um,
right.
So one of the revelations we had a at the live show is that Bobby and Karen is
now Jay.
It's different.
Yeah.
Bobby and Karen were our,
um,
our,
what's it called?
Roleplay names when we make love and I pick you up at a bar and like you act
like you smoke.
So at the bar and I'm like,
uh,
I play Bobby,
you play Karen and we do it.
I throw you out.
And Bobby's kind of a rebel,
you know,
he drives a fucking GTO and he's just like,
you don't give a fuck.
You know,
he's probably
got a few families in different cities mean I wouldn't call them families.
He's got kids in different cities and states,
but that's who I am.
I'm Bobby,
your Bobby and you're never,
I can't ever expect you to be monogamous or faithful are called call me
regularly or even text back.
No,
no,
no.
That's Karen.
By the way.
Karen and Karen always wants to change Bobby.
Well,
I was sort of carrying more like a dump truck.
Like she was just like us.
So happy to have even a moment of attention.
Yeah.
And then,
and she was willing to take the abuse,
didn't have any idea that,
I feel like Trish is a little higher up on that.
Like,
yeah.
Interesting.
So maybe she can get Bobby to be an upstanding,
well,
what why we started with Karen is that I was drinking wine and you're like,
oh,
I liked that wine breath.
Like that's a real trashy girl.
That's a Karen breath.
And that's how that started.
And then I was right,
it was wine breath,
it was wine breath and it's like,
Barbara smells really nice.
And then I left a note on your car because we were,
we were leaving in place and we were parked in the same parking lot.
And I saw your car and I thought it'd be funny to put a note on there.
Yeah.
Well I don't even remember what I was like,
Hey,
you want a date?
Yeah,
Trish,
call me Trish.
Change it on the spot,
on the spot.
Just the name change,
change my game and it,
but it changed mine too because yeah,
Trish is a little more confident,
you know what I'm saying?
Like Trish goes after the guy she wants,
she wants Bobby and should I go get him shingle and land them?
But Bobby might text her every now and they'd be,
he'll be like,
I'm up.
You are down to fuck.
Right.
But Karen doesn't even get that.
Karen's got to go find him in the bar and then he would never pursue Karen.
Yeah,
he's just like to go to sleep and Karen Lawson and he's like,
all right,
Trish is like the her games elevated.
I think you have a little more respect for Trish a little bit,
but I mean I have more respect for everybody.
Then Karen,
Karen's a dump truck and he said,
fucking mop just to come up.
What do you say to Karen when we're done?
Get Out.
Shut up and get out.
Now you say that to trash,
but Trisha push back on you just,
well you thought get out,
you fucking get out.
And he's like,
ah.
They laugh and they,
they're kind of e Karen,
Karen.
I mean Karen Goes,
oh,
okay.
And Karen leaves.
Karen is her.
That's,
yeah,
you're right.
That's Karen's is Karen
and I'm like,
get the fuck adding.
Yeah.
This girl is a total Karen.
She has no self respect.
She's making her videos and I'll shit my pants.
So here's the thing,
I think we should go on strike against calm when a neat movement,
the fuck.
Oh,
I'm so proud of you.
What a neat idea lady comes.
She's so of herself for coming up with that.
So here's the thing,
I think we should go on strike against,
uh,
come strike.
And we as in what all women,
she's talking out on behalf of all the women.
Am I right ladies?
So really she's rallying,
this applies the only people that are going to stand with her or like high
school,
college girls,
you know,
because this is not an issue for grown for women.
This is,
this is like the age where he's still read Cosmopolitan magazine and you're
talking about doing the camaraderie and stuff like that.
Yeah.
When you're a grown ass woman,
you know,
care about shower.
Yay.
Yay Fam.
Blood.
I from now on,
I'm only going and she's 12 calm of a man or put on my body to come have a man
who's willing to touch it or kiss me afterward.
No,
she do shit dummy.
By the way.
He needs to raise her fucking standard to make it clear for people not sitting
in this,
she's not,
you know,
a teen or 20 that this lady was like,
what do you,
what would you guess?
Mid Forties at best at best you.
She's right.
She's newly divorced and she's like discovering the world of young
guys.
It comes through to touch this com.
I won't either.
I'm so proud of wow.
Brave stance.
Yeah.
Martin Luther King of our era.
Right.
The Rosa parks.
The coming world.
Okay.
That men hate their calm.
It's ridiculous.
Oh.
And um,
they got to just love their calm before I'm going to like it.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
This is like all those Instagram things where it's like,
man,
you got to love yourself first.
It's a lot of those sophisticated,
this lady.
I mean,
look at the artwork here.
I said she plays obviously,
I mean there's Bach,
Beethoven,
another,
yeah.
The bike.
She probably is active and just sophisticated lady.
And she said,
you dummy.
Don't know.
It's a stupid cause there's,
there's other things happening in the world in case you hadn't noticed.
I know she's worried about her fucking come strike right now.
I'm strike,
don't take ice.
Said,
well then don't date those guys.
I know.
It's so weird.
Date.
Someone else,
Karen,
she's,
she's dating bodies and she's upset about it then don't they?
Bobbies don't they Bobby?
There's all kinds of other shit you can do besides Bobby.
Grow up a little bit.
Speaking of come the 50 shades of gray movie.
We were scrolling through the films,
the Itunes,
movies,
God,
and we were like,
cause we were,
I'm going to watch it eventually.
We should make a point about this for his first,
you know,
obviously that book first came out and it was a worldwide phenomenon,
right?
Every woman bought this book in the world.
It felt like,
and then there was such anticipation about the casting of the original,
right?
Saying,
right,
right.
The buildup and then,
Oh my God,
the movie is coming out.
People thought this is going to be on par with the dramatic following and the,
you know,
the excitement around that book and that movie I saw,
I was like,
you know what?
This book is such a hit.
I didn't read the book but I'll see this movie.
Of course it was a pile of shit.
Terrible,
terrible mood.
Well I'll tell you a little secret cause I read the book.
To me the book is a pile of shit to really,
yeah.
It was like,
you know s and m light.
I did an episode about,
about the whole thing on that.
See Pro the first movie in the book.
Okay.
So if you want to,
let's do it.
It's in the back catalog somewhere.
But I,
it's not even s and m.
It's like it's an,
it's childish like their sexuality,
the girls a virgin in the book and that's her first and then the movie too and
it's her first time having sex with him and she has like five orgasms.
I'm like shit like that.
We are like,
okay.
The first time you had sex she had five orgasms here.
Right.
And like it's naive.
I don't know.
Apparently it just seems it's very childish.
The whole fantasy of being rescued by this guy.
My cousin loves it,
loves it.
Some women.
This is really,
this is in their wheelhouse.
It's the strong man who does everything for you.
It takes care of you.
Maybe that's,
that's part of it.
I don't know.
Who knows man.
I Dunno.
I just remember that the,
here's my criticism of that movie.
It was just so boring and the story was so lame.
I mean,
nothing happened.
Yeah,
there was the,
the stakes weren't there and just you could see that like,
yeah,
this young impressionable girl and the successful good looking guy and you're
like,
okay.
And then when he would kind of play with her,
it wasn't,
you didn't go like,
Oh shit.
Like,
oh,
that's crazy.
She's getting whipped again.
And then,
um,
the whole thing was like,
will she or won't she sign his s and m contract?
And then she does the end.
He was like,
wow.
Fucking deal.
Second part.
And just the trailer.
No sense.
It makes no sense.
It looks like they cut together some of their favorite shots.
She's beautiful.
That girls really particularly good looking people,
but it's the same song.
They just redid a gammy leg is so crazy right now.
And then it makes no sense.
And then the rating for rotten tomatoes,
it got a nine a 9% which is fucking,
it's bad.
Your vin diesel movie,
Vin Diesel,
I think scored a 7% right.
Not a lot of single digit.
Not a lot.
I mean,
you see them,
you know,
teens means your garbage.
And again,
you can disagree with obviously a bunch of critics,
but when that many say it's,
it's,
it's a Turd.
Yeah.
It's pretty bad.
Well,
a single digit single digit,
really 90% people that saw that movie and we reviewed it,
we were like,
this sucks.
Yeah.
It's too bad because it was hugely successful franchise.
Well,
the book,
you know,
I was one of the books,
I'm just funny.
I said I couldn't do
it.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
It's definitely a card one.
The book,
it's really just sex scene,
sex scene,
sexy.
And he's chasing after her sex xx,
you know,
but like s and m like,
oh,
but it's not even SNM.
No.
From what I understand about that community,
uh,
that,
that is like s and m light.
Oh my,
it's like housewife.
Snm Blindfolding yes.
Super lame.
Oh yeah.
It was like when you watch those lame ass Skinemax movies,
totally.
100%.
And they're humping like super fast and they're like,
oh,
they're like porno girls doing softcore.
So they're terrible actors.
Yeah.
And then that's,
it's,
it's terrible.
He's terrible.
There's all good one though.
Yeah.
We saw a nocturnal animals.
Nocturnally missions.
Yeah.
Internal emissions.
How's great.
Tom Ford directed the designer.
The,
the famous designer who knew I had no idea that guy was making movies.
Well,
he did a single man,
which was a really good mood,
I think.
So it's really good movie.
You ever saw a single man?
I don't remember.
I think you did Julianne Moore and remember,
I like her.
Yeah,
it's really good.
Okay.
This was a man.
I was more impressed that he wrote this.
That's astounding.
It was such a great script and stories and Jake Jolen Cox in it who's just a
horribly unattractive and uh,
Amy Amy Adams apples and I like her.
She's really good.
Yeah,
that's a really good high recommendation on that one.
I mean,
it's entertaining.
You know,
it's a suspenseful.
I liked it.
And the account and we launched that last week.
We forgot to mention that one.
Yeah.
That was good to the accountant.
That was pretty interesting.
Guy was like Asperger.
Yeah,
yeah.
He had Asperger's.
Autism.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
Asperger is a form of autism.
Yeah.
Like a more mild,
you know,
on the scale.
Yeah.
Right.
Like they're,
they're so socially somewhat functional.
Right?
Yeah.
Just like not there.
They're not as good Asperger's,
not as good as picking up on social cues.
If somebody,
let's say not on the,
uh,
you know,
the spectrum,
but um,
compared to somebody with like,
yeah,
strong.
I think there's a few comics,
Asperger's that we've known over the years hold for sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
Absolutely.
Well,
yeah.
Um,
would you ever date your mom?
I would date.
My mom is so horrible that I don't get to,
uh,
enjoy all these.
I don't get to play my drops today because of that fucking technique.
Oh,
that's fine.
I play that said,
we don't have any drops today.
We do have some,
but I don't have that one.
I mean Sirius Xm.
God,
we live inside studio G.
We're waiting for Facebook now to catch up the studio to dude,
can I tell you
saying,
speaking of Asperger's,
yeah.
I would not be surprised if Garth is on the spectrum.
Yes.
Why?
This is why.
This is what I haven't been able to put my finger on.
That's wrong.
That's off about him.
If you watch how he talks and how he is,
he is not emotionally connected to anything he says it's,
it's all an effect.
I'm telling you.
Yeah.
I remember when he was,
we watched a video of him with the birthday cake.
I don't know if we're going to be seeing that.
Right.
Well,
we'll watch it just watches.
There's not a genuine emotional connectedness to him.
Even when he was being interviewed by was a Barbara Walters and he was like,
it's just like snacks.
It was very,
it seemed rehearsed like this is what people say.
This is a shocking thing that people say,
oh,
I wouldn't be surprised,
but he seems real phony Bologna.
He has.
There's a room here that they've called inside studio g.
He's such a Dad Boehner.
He's like the most famous dad boner for sure.
That there is,
he's like the chairman Jesse and empires.
And then over here cog love one another.
Oh boy.
Boy who is a big phony.
See what I'm saying?
No,
it's like he checks off all the boxes of what it is to be a successful country
star.
Love it.
I love everybody.
I love my fans.
Thank you for joining me is bullshit.
Yeah.
That's kind of bullshit.
Welcomed inside studio g first here and a,
I like it that way.
Really cool.
Yeah,
but that's why we think he's funny.
I think he's kind of autistic and I wouldn't be surprised when we think he's
funny because he's autistic because there's something not connecting.
I'm saying he's weird.
That's well,
yeah,
let's leave it up on some things.
Definitely weird.
Yeah,
but he's not autistic.
I think something's doing.
Something's weird about them for sure.
Uh,
like a little uncomfortable as it was almost like this is a bad idea or poorly
executed.
Maybe it is.
All his social media stuff is poorly executed.
It's just like if you told your dad social media,
that's why it's funny because he doesn't,
he's uncomfortable almost doing it.
Well,
it's too contrived for social media.
You've gotta be way looser,
Bro.
Like he doesn't need to be a studio g.
Even this room,
it doesn't feel like a studio because there's just three things hang in and a
desk.
But like in a small child's dust that he's sitting on with nothing on it.
So it feels like they just put stuff in a room and they were like this studio g
it is.
I got,
he's annoyed.
Is that supposed to supposed to [inaudible] birthday.
So that's his lady.
She comes in with a birthday cake.
She's looking fat.
His,
his woman.
Yes,
she was.
That's his woman.
Yeah.
Dude,
she's gained some weight.
Yeah,
no.
Well,
you know Bert loss and stuff and someone else got to put it on inside out
happen.
So weight loss go.
Yeah,
Dude.
She doesn't look capitated right there.
Yeah.
What staring up like,
yeah.
When the knock happen,
he was like,
Oh,
is that supposed to happen?
He didn't like,
Ah,
Ooh.
That's,
see that's the real guy.
Yeah.
That,
that's the guy.
Yeah.
He doesn't want his fans to say yep.
That's the guy who if you're waiting on him,
yeah.
And you bring the wrong yeah.
Dish.
That's the real guy.
Yeah.
There's Garth.
He being the wrong thing at the table is full beards.
It doesn't work on it.
It looks great.
Actually.
I like,
I mean,
I liked beards.
I like you.
So,
yeah,
that's true.
She does.
Our corn is a fantastic
man.
When you're married to the bomb,
this is what she like.
Get on your year of birth.
New in your marriage.
Gorgeous cake.
Fat Check we talking about.
She's,
she's Husky.
Trish.
Is that her?
Is that her name?
Trish.
Trish,
yeah.
Trish was so cute.
Trish.
Trish got Husky?
No,
she got,
she definitely got bigger.
Yeah.
That's a good life man.
You know,
it is a good life.
Shit.
Sorry,
my brain's Fried Prada.
Awesome job.
Okay.
Uh,
inside studio g,
is that supposed to happen?
Oh,
Hey,
question for you.
You have a mentor that would ask Garth sweetness.
Okay,
so he calls them an ask Garth and then he doesn't know sweetness to dad move.
Is that an Asca Garth?
Sweeten it.
Can we see that move again?
Sweetness
question for you.
You have a mentor that would ask Garth sweetness.
Okay.
Yeah.
He does not want to be doing this.
No.
All right.
Like you can see,
watch what happens right here.
When he gets ready to play this,
you're going to love this little part right here where you look right at the
right time.
Watch this.
Just the instant cuts,
right?
Yeah.
He's the guy that brings them to their feet.
There it is.
See what happens when he does that.
He's great at it.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Jesse says,
Gee,
we just won't be sponsoring more that we won't be talking about one of the
positions.
Jesse says,
well,
what is behind the scenes stuff?
It's pretty cool.
Yeah,
it is cool.
What's that?
We're going to have any insight.
Studio g we just won't be sponsoring more of that.
We won't be talking about one of the positions says,
well,
love all of this behind the scenes stuff.
Thank you.
It's pretty cool,
man and [inaudible] and what I,
what I find out,
so let's see.
It's cool to start texting me or telling me stories about how during the show
they'll start to watch the crew,
which is cool too because the crew is as much part of our show as again as a
drummer.
The guitar player.
Yeah,
it was Garth Brooks.
Nice.
I'm Northbrook says I'm not special.
I love this phony.
The third person is the ultimate places.
Yeah,
it's the crew is just as important as the drummer,
the guitar player,
even as Garth Brooks is.
So everyone's important.
That guy,
what I find out,
so as people start texting me or telling me stories about how during the show
they'll start to watch the crew,
which is cool because the crew is as much part of our show as again as the
drummer,
the guitar player,
this Garth Brooks is this crew,
Garth Brooks as gee.
Wow.
As important as GE is such another country music thing of like I have,
everybody's just equal.
I'm just as important as the grips.
Like some,
some of them are,
not that they're not important,
but one of you guys,
if one of you doesn't show up for the night,
kind of ruins the whole thing.
You know what?
I'm happy birthday.
So we missed that.
That's what he said to Jake.
He says he's doing himself happy birthday to g baby birthday.
So cool buddy.
Sweetness,
sweetness,
sweetness.
Such an old dad.
It's pretty cool man.
And then it's,
it's neat.
Such dad boner.
He's,
he,
he is the greatest.
He's an exemplary dad.
Boner now.
And you know,
he's probably a pretty good dad.
You know,
he's faking that too.
I feel like you have contempt for him that I had just,
there's something about this guy that doesn't,
it doesn't rub me the right way.
I just think that we're going to find out in a few years some dark shit.
Oh,
it's definitely some dark shit.
He's a little too Cosby,
you know,
like,
orchestrated and clean and everything's like,
isn't this neat?
Great.
That's what I'm talking about.
I know.
Especially like a famous guy who's got access to tons of puss and whatever he
wants.
Yeah.
Gimme a fucking break,
you know,
and I know he's got demons,
Howard guy.
Yeah,
he's a weird dude.
We're going to know about that stuff later.
Um,
do you see the spider in the sink?
You saw that this,
this is a couple that they're on vacation I think during mom's Trillia.
Yup.
And uh,
they find a big,
so there's some big ass spiders there.
Lots of critters and mom's Australia and the,
uh,
recording
so big.
It's huge.
So she's,
she's really scared.
The recording keeps pretty,
you know,
scared too.
But so he's got the,
uh,
they're getting a spray out,
you know,
they're going to try to just dose it.
Dowsett
I love the subtitle.
The subtitle is a genius.
I said,
Vicky,
maybe they there,
but she's
obviously,
she's not Australia.
She's,
you know,
well,
she has a,
she has an Australian accent,
which is so fascinating.
Right,
right.
So she's learned English.
She learned English in Australia.
Right.
But she's not a native Australian.
Was there.
Um,
so then she gears up and they line them up here.
It's funny to hear someone with that accent.
There she goes.
[inaudible]
now she kind of dropped a big word there.
She sure did.
Never heard.
I've never heard a Chinese Australian dropped that on a spider.
That's what I'm saying that,
well that's why were at your mom's House special.
Special.
Yeah.
I've done the,
the lead up to something like that where you just scream
for any of that.
You dropped the and Bama.
I didn't drop it in bond on it,
but I dropped a,
you know,
a lot of
[inaudible].
That's kind of like running into battle.
That's moderate,
you know.
Right.
The spider that's domestic.
It's domestic battle.
Right.
That's a brain farm moment.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
totally.
It was like,
oh my God.
Like you just go for it.
Yeah.
She was terrified.
I was scared.
Yeah.
Dad,
do you have the biggest bugs,
man?
I remember back during road rules.
Oh my God.
So do I,
sorry,
sorry.
So we used to stay in youth hostels.
That's a secret.
You never really slept in the Winnebago.
We would check into youth hostels.
Everybody's just drill on each other and those houses,
no,
actually no,
we didn't.
Nobody slept each other on my cast.
So wow.
The Lights,
the crew lights would be on in our bedroom.
We'd all sleep in the same room.
In bunk beds.
Yeah.
And the lights will be on,
so all the bugs would be attracted to the lights.
So when the crew would leave at night and they turn lights out,
there would be a layer of bugs on the ceiling,
like a layer of huge moths and I would always get the top,
the top bunk,
because I like top bunk and the bugs would just fall on me all night and I would
put the sheet over my head and just look.
I'd feel them falling on me.
It was so gnarly.
Australia is just so gnarly.
Okay.
That's your bugs are a keychain.
Nothing to kill him.
Why did they just had to fall on me and go away?
It was horrible.
I don't like,
I really don't like that.
I really know.
That's not cool or neat.
No.
One time I was in Lima and a fucking sewer rat.
The house.
Ooh.
And they had a body guard,
like security guy that worked there.
He beat it with a stick and killed it.
Damn.
This big are fine with a stick.
Yeah.
He got like a mop or something,
just like club the shit out of it.
How big are they?
It was massive.
It was a massive thing.
As big as Betsy.
It looked like,
I mean,
no,
not quite that big,
but it was pretty big.
Yeah.
Dude and Cuba when
I did,
um,
that naval show [inaudible] they have those,
uh,
what are those called?
And Rats.
Oh yeah,
they look like,
yeah,
like that.
Those are nasty.
I remember you came back with all those videos of them.
Ah,
yeah.
And they were just everywhere.
Yeah.
They tried to kill them all the time cause they overpopulate so much.
Oh there's a guy on base who drives around with a 22 and he's just supposed to
shoot everyone and that doesn't even put a dent in the problem.
Like he'll kill 20,
30,
40 at a time,
you know,
and they're like,
it doesn't even put a dent in our problem with kind of a fun job though,
when you think about that was a blast.
Yeah.
If you have a no ambition,
what a great job.
I mean,
if you're stuck on an island and working on base,
that's kind of the the truck and drive around and shoot these things like
fucking awesome.
Did you and your bro just shooting these disgusting creatures that are
overpopulated?
That probably makes it easier because they don't know.
Not Cute.
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
Ah,
I got to be so nasty.
Cuba.
There is some island.
I did a Gig on some military base here in California and they,
they were overcome with a,
was it raccoons?
Yeah.
Raccoons just,
Oh,
so many dude.
And you see these so many.
These are,
we could feed them.
They come right up to you.
They didn't give a fuck.
You see these fuckers?
They're big man.
Oh Damn Dude.
That is as big as our dogs all over the island,
man.
All over.
Look at this motherfucker drinking,
drinking those guys.
Bottle dude.
Yeah,
so I guess,
you know,
maybe it's just a fear because they're new.
Maybe they're sweeter.
I know that they eat,
they're not like 'em
are sewer rats,
they just chew on but eat vegetation there.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
but fuck man,
when you saw the first time I saw one,
I think I've told this story before,
uh,
we pulled up to our first show and the lights from the van,
we're highlighting them and they weren't,
you know,
skittish.
They're just over there eating,
but they're pretty close.
So the guy was like,
you can go take a,
you know,
you can look at them.
So we all get out of the van and we start to walk over slowly and literally as
we get,
uh,
I don't know,
maybe five feet,
um,
from it,
you know,
you kind of squat a little more cause you're really taking in that you're seeing
it in person.
And as I do that,
as I leaned forward to get like a kind of good glimpse of it,
one of the other guys on the show ran his two fingers up my back.
Ah,
and I let,
yes,
I lit up like a high pitched scream that they asked me if I was joking.
You know,
they're like,
where are you doing a bit?
But that's how
gross.
All right,
cause I had that that moment.
Yeah,
I know.
Like the spider and they spook you.
It spooked,
man.
Let the record show.
By the way,
I have one,
two,
three containers of water.
How many do everyone's over this
right now?
How many do you have over it?
How many do you have?
Curious.
You have a disgusting soda and coffee.
Only dehydrating elements.
No hydration,
no dehydration.
Because this is water.
No sugar,
no artificial sweetener,
no caffeine.
Okay,
but it's like sugar water.
It's not sugar.
Fake sugar water.
It's Z via whatever we're switching.
The House has switched over from liquid to Zv.
Yeah.
I hate this because I don't like Zevia.
I don't like it.
It doesn't taste good.
I liked the clock right now I hire,
we also had a revelation about liquid.
What it makes our stomachs hurt,
couple of them,
and we keep drinking them and I keep drinking it them.
You're done.
Totally.
I'm not into them.
You're fully CVO.
Now,
here's the fun thing about Cvi.
If you,
if you'll allow me.
Okay.
Here's what I,
here's why I'm in is eve.
Yeah.
I've gone pretty,
you'd admit pretty hardcore with my no sugar into,
yeah.
Yeah.
I don't fuck with sugar at all.
Right.
Yeah.
You know,
an exception here or there,
but my day to day is no sugar.
Zevia is like Keto friendly sweetener.
Right?
Yeah.
Other words,
there's some sweeteners are like fake sweeteners that have the same effect on
your body that sugar does.
Right,
right.
This does not,
so it's a,
it's kind of an indulgence.
It makes you feel like,
like I'm a drink drinking us doing a bad girl treat and that therefore it's more
enjoyable to me.
I understand.
I understand the logic.
Yeah.
However,
it tastes like shit.
It tastes like just like a soda to me.
It's just like the gays,
but to me it makes me thirsty year and it makes my stomach feel weird.
Both the Quad Moz via too.
Why don't you marry your mound and then see you?
Why don't you,
why don't you,
oh,
awesome.
Awesome.
Um,
go ahead.
See if this is here.
I'm trying to see if this is,
uh,
I wanna I wanna find something.
Oh man,
that's what sucks about having that computer fucked is that there's been any the
f word.
I know.
Let me see if this is,
yeah,
this song.
We would have so many killer songs lately.
Yeah.
But you know how sometimes from moment to moment you get one stuck in your head?
The one that's been in my head,
like I'm hearing it as I'm falling asleep is just like the gays by DJ boy
butter.
That's what I played on the in bed last night.
It's just like,
it's just like good.
Just like the gay
here.
My son.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm your mom.
You're my son.
Ask when you
get your mom.
Yes.
I would hear my son.
I'm your mom.
You could like the gate,
like the gate.
I looked at her and she looked at me
cause like the gauge
once the,
he calls me mom.
What I mean?
Hold consenting.
Adults
ask and when you ask them,
when I looked at her and she looked at me and you're my son,
I'm your mom.
Just like the gate,
the gate.
I cannot get enough.
It's amazing.
You just like the gays.
Amazing.
I think you,
you would like goth music,
whatever music.
It sounds like goth music.
Well you know,
I liked that.
Trancey kind of Susie and the banshees.
You liked the kaleidoscope album.
You,
you've listened to that one.
Good tones on tail fan.
You love tones on tail.
Yeah.
Bauhaus.
Um,
I've been thinking of eye shadow dolls with my hands.
My ass.
I think that's Ali,
right?
Yeah.
Ali's DMZs or that guy's been cranking out the heads on this show.
Which one is that?
And then,
then he'd do the tape song as well.
Was that him?
He's on a bunch of the fart.
Hey.
Hi.
How are you?
What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?
We can't play that one.
Yeah,
for illegal.
Just the one.
Yeah.
This is it.
I love it.
Oh yeah,
this is really great.
Do blippy plastic.
I shot.
This is sounds like
that I like,
Alrighty.
I shadow dom
genius
coming out of your mom's house.
We
had a crazy playlist playing when people were filing in for the shows.
Enough People um,
push before
it where
I am going to put together a playlist.
Right.
So we're doing it finally.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Um,
about,
yes,
I will get on that.
I promise you give me just like a week or so to figure it out.
Can you play the beat box?
Dad Glass.
Holy Shit.
That one was amazed.
We did this at the live show and I just can't stop thinking about how much I
like it.
I wanted to hear it again.
Yeah,
that was amazing.
What happened was a guy took the
um,
the,
the super,
the Super Hunter Dad,
you know this guy,
this glass and guy were glass and just glass
glass and Dad.
And when that guy first killed that Moose,
he made that
crazy noise,
right?
Yeah.
Like I like using studios,
studio g sound.
That's what they say to play when they open up studio g
dad sound studio g.
So that guy,
the class
a guy made a song,
a beat box song off of his,
um,
off of those noises.
No,
the room.
Oh my God.
I love it.
Where is it?
Uh,
I shattered
my hands finger in my ass.
I can't,
you can't find a gene.
I just had it and I don't know where it is.
I just put it somewhere.
Um,
is in the early show on late show or is it
song?
Song.
I'll talk while you're doing this.
Yeah.
Um,
I think I just wanted to mention the live show stuff.
Oh,
you know,
in the past we were able to stay afterward and take pictures of people and meet
all the mommies.
But I just want you guys to know like we're not fucking dicks.
That's why we're not able to do it.
It's because the way that the shows were stacked,
the seven and the nine gray,
it was seven to nine,
nine 30.
There was no time if we will out there and do all that,
like we have to reset immediately and then by the time the nine o'clock show let
out,
it was already super late and we had to get back to baby jeans and Armani and
stuff.
So just so you guys know or not douchebags we just couldn't do it for time.
There was just no way,
you know,
it's too much.
Yeah.
Um,
I have a search going for it right now,
but I don't know where it is.
Right.
But we'll find it.
We'll find it.
If not today,
then next week.
Um,
here's what I wanted to play for you.
Uh Oh,
we have,
well,
I'll close with that.
We have another shit the thing to do then,
but right now is a good time.
Oh,
you should mention,
um,
what you have.
I'm so excite.
So finally that's deep brow has an official at seat row by cash shirt.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Congratulations.
I'm so excited.
And uh,
it's a cool shirt.
I like to design a lot.
It's black because that helps.
Yeah,
it's normal.
It's on Thomson grows merchant page.
Yeah.
Tom,
scroll.com.
You go to the,
the store takes you to a merchant ethic.
Yeah.
Check it out guys.
Also that's the Bro.
I know.
I'm on Youtube.
I record myself talking to nobody and I put that on Youtube and a,
there you go.
I'm going to interview a nonbinary person.
Oh my God.
What's Your Pronoun?
I know.
We'll find out.
Can't wait.
Yeah,
so that's excite.
Check it out.
Thank you.
That's Ebro podcast.com.
I got some big announcements for my um,
tour that I've been on.
One is that we added another show in DC at the Improv.
We added a late show Sunday,
so that'll be um,
that's available now.
We added a show in Burlington,
Vermont at higher ground.
We added a 7:00 PM show originally.
We had a later show,
um,
Seattle.
We added a show at the Moore theater that's on sale now.
So Seattle,
me rattle.
If you haven't gotten your tickets yet,
you have a chance now for the late show,
uh,
at the Moore theater at all.
That is,
um,
April 14th is that show.
So get on it.
Portland sold out really far in advance and um,
I couldn't add a show the original weekend because the next day is Easter,
so it kind of screwed with that.
So instead I'm coming back to Portland one month later.
Same venue,
Revolution Hall.
And the added show is May 13th,
so don't sleep on those.
If you haven't purchased your Portland tickets,
there's now an opportunity to go,
uh,
May 13th that is also on sale right now.
Um,
so make sure you scoop those up.
I will be,
this weekend is all sold out.
I'm looking forward to it.
Um,
Long Island,
Montclair and Atlantic city next weekend and Canada.
It's all sold out.
And then the weeks after that,
I dunno.
Look them up.
Thompson [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
I'm going to a bunch of cities.
Um,
so you know what to do.
Go,
go get this ticket.
This is the son by the way,
was instrumental by Obi wan Kenobi.
Canola ob one is one of the old school music makers on this shelf.
Absolutely love cannoli stuff.
You're so fucking great.
Um,
dates.
Okay.
February 17th and 18th.
I'm,
I'm uh,
February 17th at Hollywood.
I'm headlining the Hollywood improv and then the 18th I'm headlining.
Flappers so come see me locally in La.
April 13th through 15th,
I met the brand improv.
April 29th,
sorry.
April 28th through 29th.
I've just added Sacramento at the Sacramento punchline.
May 4th through fifth.
Phoenix fart.
Nick's Arizona.
Stand up live.
May 19th and 20th Jew Dork titties.
Gotham comedy club.
June 1st through third Denver.
What's Denver?
Oh Mom.
Hmm.
I Dunno.
Den Her Dad,
her dad,
her and her box open.
Yeah.
Denture box.
Open a comedy works downtown.
And then June 16th or 17th man friend disco at the punchline comedy club.
Uh,
so come see me there guys.
[inaudible] sims or yeah,
that'd be good.
Hey,
also check out our,
hey mommy's thanks Jean shirt.
We got that up.
But uh,
Tom square.com and the store.
Don't forget if you have some time today.
I know.
Grew along Ross sky,
you don't need to figure your home.
You don't want to,
I got it on your finger.
Yeah,
I got it.
I'm fucking ready.
I've been waiting to try these on.
Let's try it.
Which one do you want?
Oh,
take my o g one.
So we had these at the live show.
Yeah.
So we were sitting around at Korean barbecue last week planning the show and we
thought,
wouldn't it be fun to get some pup play masks?
Uh,
how's the audio?
Hold on,
let me help you.
I'm boring my fetish,
man.
I'm wearing mine now too.
Yours is a little different,
but the same idea.
You know the same idea.
What do you think of a burn?
What's your ass smells like?
What'd you call them?
Balls smell like?
Well,
what do you think?
Do you like the experience?
I understand.
I understand the thrill of the tight laid techs
smell what your nose smell like at different times of the day.
Good.
What about the smell?
It smells really powerful in the,
that effort,
but I'm working on getting a more keen sense of smell.
Nice to different parts of your underwear.
Uh,
feels right.
I think I should take it off.
It's horrifying.
Wait,
it's horrible.
Yeah,
no,
it's triers on.
Yeah,
try that.
That's terrible.
So Tom's got the original fetish mass for those of you just listening.
These are,
so this is the original black terrifying one.
And then I got another one that's a German shepard with crazy mouth open and
crazy eyes.
And it is terrifying as well.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
it's pretty crazy.
If you saw somebody walk up and this you don't think friendly,
you don't think like,
oh that's pretty,
that's a friendly guy.
This is terrible.
This smells so bad.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Horrible.
So we had the thing going about,
which was more terrifying and oh yeah.
People I'd be,
we'll go black one because it's the fetish mask right away.
But I still could feel like there's something creepier about the non fetish
mask.
I do.
I don't think so.
About the,
the,
the googly eyes.
Cause you are realize or in that this has fake eyes in it.
That's what,
that's what it is.
The dead eyes.
It's dead.
Fake eyes.
Yeah.
How many walks up in this [inaudible] you don't know what's happening.
But blue band made a good point about the original fetish mask is that there's
no expression.
Oh,
that's
terrible.
Right?
I know,
I got it all.
You're right.
That's way worser.
C.
Yeah.
Wait,
try this again.
Do it again again.
Well,
let me see.
I want to see the contrast.
So this is the original fetish pup play.
Oh,
that is just terrifying.
See that's like a rapist or a serial killer.
Like it's,
it's traditionally scary,
but it's like it's telling you it's scary,
right?
That one is misleading.
Try that one again please.
Fucking prop show today.
I want to see.
Yeah,
that one could be,
I'm robbing a bank or I'm raping you.
Oh my God.
Your beard is sticking through the mouth holes.
Others,
peers sticking in his mouth.
Definitely.
We were terrible.
Do you feel sexy though?
I mean I get that people like some people just like wearing latex,
right?
It doesn't personally arouse me,
but I understand why it's a thrill for someone.
I do.
I get it.
It's a tactile thing.
But wouldn't it ripped super tight on you if you were to zip it up?
Cause we couldn't zip it over your head.
Yeah.
Cause it would trap your hair.
Doesn't get caught.
Tear.
Your hair gets caught and then you have 10 Vaseline up,
I think.
Yeah,
that would be,
that would not be good,
dude.
I don't like those at all.
I don't enjoy wearing that shit at all.
No,
I'm not.
It's so scary,
right?
No,
it's just not,
it's not my world.
We got,
speaking of Garth,
we got another,
uh,
Dad Boehner here.
Oh,
sweet dad Boehner video.
Cool of a dad who was driving and he saw a funny sign.
All right.
So I'm driving home and I'm heading down near the auto mall and I pass this
strip club.
I glanced up at it at the,
I just glanced at it like I'm driving by and something that I saw come across
the school made me stop and want to film this and I was fucking crying.
Let's see what it is.
It's so,
so funny.
Yeah.
And it should be coming up soon.
Oh,
right here.
Okay,
man,
he quit being a dad.
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
That was so funny to him that he wanted to quit battery.
You realize that that's what's out there,
but that's,
yeah.
When you're like,
I wonder if this jokes good enough.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Okay.
That guy,
I thought gluten free lap dances was the funniest thing he'd ever heard.
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
So the sign is a scroll and it says gluten free lap dances.
And he hasn't looked over.
I,
I salute you for having a sense of humor.
Yeah.
About it.
It's funny.
Good.
Yeah.
Would you laugh?
No,
but that's
the thing with Dads,
is it?
Yeah.
They really get tickled by stuff most of us don't.
Like.
I think what it is is like your life gets so mundane as we've discovered being
parents that you just get excited about little stuff because you don't
experience,
the world is mine.
At least I don't like Shit,
man.
I watch a Ryan Gosling movie,
you know,
and I think it's like the best thing I've ever seen.
Right.
I watched fucking no strings attached with Ash Ashton Kutcher and Allie
[inaudible].
This is a funny movie.
Yeah,
I was,
yeah,
I really thought it was good.
So your,
your standards change when you're locked in the house.
Well,
yeah,
when you're dealing with kids from,
you know,
you're,
you're so innocent,
your existence gets way more innocent.
Interesting.
I've never actually thought of it like that.
No,
I'm smarter.
Come on man.
Glue.
I like that a lot.
Let me see if this came in while we were doing this.
Free Lab.
Dad says the funniest things ever seen.
So stupid.
You're my son.
I'm your mom.
Um,
cause I wanted to set this up.
I uh,
I spoke to my dad.
Oh,
thank God.
It's that what our guy,
where the,
Oh wait,
the best part about our masks by the way.
Yeah.
Our pup masks is that you were out of town when they arrived there and I took
him out of like Amazon boxes because I bought them on Amazon by the way,
using our banner.
You can find anything on Amazon.
Yeah.
I fucking fetish masks.
You name it.
So I had them out in our bedroom just like,
Hey dad,
I'm sorry.
Throw him on our couch.
They're like our goal seat.
Yeah.
And,
um,
our,
uh,
our nanny sometimes makes up our room and I came back and she had neatly folded
both like fetish masks.
Yeah.
And I'll,
I,
I was like,
Oh shit.
You think she had any idea what's going on?
No.
Kind of like,
remember the time in the house keeper put your cock rings and plastic bags.
Yeah.
So she had to have noun.
That was something hygienically not a favorite part about buying those cock
rings by the way.
Well not maybe not those with the first one I bought cock rings was that I
bought large thinking in my mind,
large adult.
Right.
Not Enormous.
Deg Large.
Yeah.
I saw Lars and I was like,
oh,
like,
like a large t shirt,
like the gays adult.
Right.
So I bought a shirt,
a cock ring for like a giant cock.
Yeah.
I could fold that cock ring and to and still stick my fingers to the sides of
it.
Cause it,
how'd they get a housekeeper?
Must've been really impressed.
No,
that's what I'm saying.
That was like,
I'm s I'm talking about the first I ever bought.
Oh
does she put was just a normal one.
Yeah,
but I think she probably thought,
I don't think she knows what that is.
I think she does because she put it in a Ziploc bag and put it in,
kept it by bed.
Go clean the bay in the bag as if to say,
this is disgusting that you just left it out.
There needs to be in a plastic container.
Dummy.
What if she was on a com strike?
She probably is after that was on one.
He's like,
I'm not doing no come [inaudible] man,
she's cleanup so much of your calm just does our bedsheets and stuff.
Yeah.
She doesn't realize she's doing it though.
She knows she wears plastic gloves.
That's true.
She knows.
She knows you're an animal that Lou,
she doesn't,
you know,
make it a thing of it.
She doesn't make a thing of,
oh,
make a thing of it,
you know.
Right.
Are I talked to the top dog and I got,
I got him to what?
You wanted them to speak Spanish and try some Spanish.
Now the sound is kind of shitty because he's on,
he's driving and he's on his Bluetooth,
but you know you can still hear him.
Hey Buddy.
How you doing?
Good.
MMM,
I would not do,
um,
he my brother.
Yeah.
Oh Nice.
You guys going to hang out
tomorrow?
Yeah,
I'm going to spend the night Saint Mary's,
Georgia.
The end.
We're going to hang out tomorrow and then drive back yard tomorrow evening.
Yeah.
That's why mom only has to be alone.
You know,
she hates when I go away.
Yeah.
You know it's funny that uh,
next to your brother,
like you're,
you're like a choir girl cause he's such a savage.
My brother.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
it's true.
We're at,
we're at rock bottom.
Oh that guys,
we don't mean it like sexually fun or anything like that.
Savage barbarian.
Yeah.
He just said such a guy.
Ultimate.
Yeah.
Burned the old club one time he salmon lodge and he blows his nose with his
Appian.
Yeah.
Any Danny hasn't UTM and out of the years.
And then he puts the use used cute and his shirt pocket.
What the fuck?
Man,
that's so gnarly.
I remember that.
I know.
It's gnarly.
That was gnarly.
Jesus.
You know
what,
the military does it turn,
you know,
when you're around guys a lot.
I mean,
he had to do overseas tours,
the Jessica,
you know,
Vietnam,
Laos and Thailand.
And when you're hanging around just guys,
you know,
you really don't have to worry about mannerism gay.
Right?
Yeah.
That's so true.
Because when he's around me,
like my dad,
especially if he's with his brother,
they,
um,
they fall apart more.
Oh,
I started taking pride in like being,
it's like their hands,
they start to be more gross.
Yeah.
Remember when you wanted a massage at our wedding and rock biter thought that
was the queerest thing that he'd ever heard and it's are really fucking changed
since my day.
Just like a,
it's a resort.
Yeah.
Read a resort.
And he's like,
what are you doing?
I was like,
I'm gonna get a massage.
And he was like,
what?
I was like,
you know,
just get a massage.
He was like,
I guess it's really changed as my time.
I got up and walked away.
Like disgusted.
[inaudible] petty.
Yeah.
Lane his mind.
He's not going to get my facial and stuff to let me do your eyebrows.
So uncle,
he looks like a rock layer.
Yeah,
yeah,
I see that,
that,
that definitely,
yeah.
You know,
I mean,
you know,
I use it,
I use a knife and fork because I have to.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I live by myself.
I probably just use my aunts.
Sure.
Absolutely.
It was a lot easier.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean,
that's what the gay man used to do,
you know.
No,
they didn't have one.
I just,
for me,
very astute observation.
Yes.
Yeah.
They just use here.
Used to having her and grabbing you.
What happened?
And you know,
you're ever watch the old,
the old viking movies,
you know,
I mean,
you're talking about the savage group would be people.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
You would have been
good and that you would have been good in that era.
I couldn't,
you know,
I have to dye my hair blond,
but I could've been a Nike.
I think so.
Hey.
Um,
I was thinking about your,
you know,
the fact that you've been married to a Spanish speaker for this long now.
There you go.
Gee,
what anniversaries?
It's going to be 41 or 40,
40 inches.
It's going to be 41
41.
Jesus.
How much Spanish do you think you know?
MMM,
I know,
judge.
Key sentences,
phrases.
I would say I don't know.
A scale of one to 10.
What are some of your key ones that you know for sure.
I like,
say Kyla by,
by four due to Jack.
What?
Fuck.
Say like how by by,
by two.
Joe Did,
he said No.
Uh,
my mouth drops for your pussy.
Oh my gosh.
He makes my mouth dry.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
He'll tell me that.
I don't want that.
Right.
He says that to your mom.
Well,
that's what he,
I'd never heard him say that before.
He says that to your mom came.
Must he says that and then they do it.
Yeah.
Or right after they do it.
Oh,
my guy,
I love Bob Arctic.
Jack.
Jack Jesus.
Whoa.
I have no,
never.
I never heard you say that one before.
I know that one.
Who taught you that?
I don't know.
I think
your mother may have,
I kind of defaulted into that years ago about,
you know,
but I know achy Arrow
commerciality Kate towel.
No accent.
Of course.
Cape Town.
Yes.
Spanish is amazing.
Really Nice kind of motel.
Yamas Kate Towel.
Um,
what did I use to say?
What did I use to say to you when we would go on a walk?
When I was a kid?
Yeah.
That was carry me.
For those of you who don't know car,
the reason I made them say it cause he tells the story
and you are a little shit.
We'd go on a walk and you'd say [inaudible]
okay.
Oh Man.
Yep.
His accent is amazing.
Packable and are you from I can't tell him.
Mexico City.
Madrid.
It's so,
it's so nice.
Yeah.
Oh
does,
uh,
does knowing that much of another language make you want to explore parts of the
world you haven't been to?
I'm done.
What about,
um,
how about Rome?
You want to go to Rome?
See where the lions ate.
The Christians.
Yeah.
I think that
I'd like to see the VAT again.
Okay.
I think there's a lot of church history there,
but we have a fun time.
Oh,
that's a trouble in most ways.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm really not interested for some.
King took a shit 2000 years ago.
What about the museums and the artwork?
You know,
I've been to all those museums after a while they all look like,
you know,
I mean,
I did that when I went to Spain,
which you know the grid really well.
Yeah.
Why are you,
Maria and I were going through all these museums and it's basically some picture
of some,
some guy being tortured by the Spanish or one of a thousand pictures of,
you know,
Christ in different,
religious pictures.
But after a while,
Oh
God,
of course.
You know,
the traditional paintings all look the same.
You get the,
I make the Salvador Dali museum in and spanked.
By the way,
I'm super impressed that he even pulled that up and the fact that it goes,
doesn't he have a museum in Spain that he remembers that I took him to one,
but I'm so impressed that he,
yeah.
Yeah,
he might,
there's a brainer.
Sophia has,
um,
I think modern artwork,
you,
you know,
some of that stuff is interesting to look at because you don't see my job,
after a while
bored pretty quickly.
Why I tell you the museums,
I don't get bored.
I like the,
all the museums or Washington DC,
the American district museum,
Natural History Museum of Science and Industry in Chicago,
you know,
so I like,
American history.
I,
you know,
and I've seen a copy museum,
I mean the gold museum and after a while it's all gold.
Okay.
Yeah.
Although they do have that nice torture museum there.
I went to see that.
What headquarters is Spanish.
His Spanish are really good at that.
You know,
they,
they had this rule that you're not supposed to draw blood when you charge you
some money.
Yeah.
I was part of the magic and you know,
when,
this is where the religious things,
but they were really good at like Callie limbs out doing thing is that,
you know,
once you,
once you call somebody,
you know,
use the rack.
I'm somebody that is beyond repair hills people.
Yeah.
Basically.
And they don't,
they cannot be thinking at that point.
Right.
That's nice.
They're basically,
since I've been watching what I eat and I'm at a more disciplined,
I am now,
it's been,
I haven't had any,
you know,
I stay with,
I guess the best way to say it.
I stay in the really the,
the four to five range all the time now.
It's kind of Nice.
Yeah,
it is.
But you know,
I haven't had a water too.
You have a long time.
That must mean you're hydrating too.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
And I haven't had,
you know,
I did have a,
uh,
seven recently,
you know,
I'll get like some kind of bucking place,
but that came and went and,
Yep.
So,
uh,
she,
he really keeps you up to date on all these.
Yeah.
Just kind of goes into it too,
if you notice that.
Oh yeah,
no,
I'm prompted.
Yeah.
And a seven for a reminder for our listeners has,
is all liquid loose.
Yeah.
No.
What I love about the art art in the museum,
she's like,
you seen it already?
Just see it gold.
All right.
I'd seen it.
Yeah,
I know.
After a while.
Is that you just a lot of gold.
Yeah.
I heard that all that smelled really bad.
You said,
Oh,
you have no idea.
I don't know what happened in my gut,
even by my standards of being growth,
which are extremely high.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's really,
really smell.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Oh,
I made it there yet.
You don't have somebody at a meter.
You're like a breathalyzer or burst smell,
you know?
Yeah.
This,
it had been four times the limit.
Okay.
That's a pretty vivid picture.
I thank you for that.
Yeah.
I always like to put things in.
You know,
when I try to do is put things and you know,
so people can identify with me.
Okay.
No,
I know.
That makes sense.
So do you realize what's been sitting under our noses this entire time?
Did you pick up on it?
Right.
We have been speaking to a,
you know,
super champion.
Oh my God,
you're ready.
He drops,
you know,
every five seconds and,
okay,
yeah.
Okay.
For sure.
But you know,
it was what Mike,
we are,
you know what I'm saying?
You know,
I'm feeling,
you know,
talking about,
and you know,
this huge and blue band picked up on it.
I made a top dog,
you know,
super.
Oh my God.
Amazing.
No,
you know,
well,
you know there's,
you know,
you know it's right.
You know,
I was like,
you know,
oh wow.
Amazing.
He said,
you know,
and the funny thing is,
blue band,
I had recorded this call and then I was playing it back,
you know,
it was running it through the system here,
and I know I said it too,
but during that playback,
I heard him say it 40 times,
right.
And I made note of it just like,
wow,
he really says it a lot.
Half an hour later,
blue band emails.
He says,
this whole time we've been sitting on a,
you know,
Gold Mine Gold Mine.
It's your dad.
Wow.
And you found this,
but it's,
you know,
super got together.
I also,
my mind is blown.
I ran over,
I grabbed that flash drive.
I found I was able to transfer over that just glass and Oh,
cool.
Oh Great.
This is the guy that made the beat box out of the judge glass in the hunting.
Now sort of sound
go down right there.
Mm mm mm mm mm.
Isn't that amazing?
That is,
that is fucking who is this whole,
damn,
that was so good.
Who Know,
how do people even hear a song and you know,
just glass and beat box by Dj Dad,
Moose and ambling and unbelievable.
It's so good.
There's definitely no other podcasts that has discovered this level of musical
talent out there.
I'm serious.
Well,
and it's interesting too,
because this with the,
hey mommy,
thanks genes phenomenon.
It's like,
you think it can't get any better.
Yeah.
And then some other mommy comes and escalates that game.
Right.
Like we thought we'd exhausted the Jess glass and guy.
Yeah.
And then this shows up.
It's just,
it's so fascinating.
It's so good.
Yeah.
It's really crazy,
man.
Pepperoni proceeded.
Which one has,
should I,
uh,
drag over a file here?
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
Just classes.
Just glass,
glass and glass.
A file.
There's a gender non Binary Pronoun here.
I got to,
maybe you can,
oh,
that's from last week.
God dammit.
I it,
the week before was three 81 last time we did it.
Yeah.
Wait,
here we go.
Here's some that I don't think we have played.
And you see,
oh hey mommy,
I think so.
Angle,
just gloss for minute
or on that glass in your lost for a minute.
And these do they call me?
Hey talking chicken.
Yeah.
Chicken.
Yes.
Honest,
the arcane weekday paces of five,
nine,
21 in like the family bucket.
This stuff.
We have the Manga and then the mega pocket,
uh,
did jeans.
Could I get a number one?
Uh,
with no onion.
And then another dealt with my plastic gene as well.
Okay.
One more time.
Uh,
another double double with a nine as well.
Okay.
Uh,
and a sprite.
Keeping myself hydrated.
A sprite to keep myself hydrated.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Okay.
A non Muray mommy.
I said.
All right man.
Awesome.
Perfect.
Cool.
Thank you Molly.
I liked it.
He's broke everyone.
No one breaks.
Know he broke.
Doesn't Brendan high pay shorter.
When you're ready.
Hi.
Mommy can describe a,
a
regular sites or you captured.
Please said
hey mommy.
Like when they go right into it.
Yeah,
he's wearing a DJ.
Dab My yes.
I love it.
It's really fun.
I want one.
Um,
yeah,
I'm good.
Excuse me a second.
Just crossing.
Um,
oh,
I to get something for Ben.
I'll grab a similar in scroll as well,
please.
Hi.
When you're ready.
Hi Mommy.
Can I describe a regular regulars?
So that one that you suggested here.
Oh,
em.
Gee.
Are you guys ready?
Buckle up for this one.
Third one.
Let's see.
Downloads here.
Um,
do you guys see who that is?
Hey mom,
how are you doing today?
I'm doing,
I'm just glancing.
Can I get a number one
for people listening?
This is a police officer in uniform and his squad car.
Yeah.
There's a gun behind him.
There's not a rack.
Shotgun.
Yeah.
I mean he's on the job right now
with a vanilla iced coffee.
Please.
Let's keep it high and tight.
Go large.
Uh,
I just want to weight loss competition.
Trying to reward myself,
you know.
Anything else?
Um,
do you guys buy a chance?
Carry Lacroix sparkling water?
No,
we do not know.
What kind of,
do you have?
What do you have?
What do you carry?
Water
we have,
if I need,
just bring in your water and then we have just not water.
Okay.
I'll take two bottles of the shiny please.
The Shawnee.
Okay.
That's two right?
Yeah.
Great.
I have a couple friends that think they're the water chance,
but we all know who the real one is.
That's it.
Thank you.
Unbelievable.
We'd like to try and make cookies for knowledge today.
Oh No,
thank you.
Thanks jeans.
Amazing.
Well,
law enforcement,
we've had improv comedy club phone answer.
Now policemen.
We've had people working in liquor stores.
That was a,
it's so funny.
The guy before was Jared.
I don't know the police officer's name.
Oh,
I'm just glassing ne She's,
can you give me one second?
Sorry Mommy.
I'm ready.
You're like,
oh,
can I get a a number 10
right?
Mushy.
Purple.
Do you don't have grape juice?
Northern a great showed up.
Was she brought Jean died.
Can I get a mountain dew Baja blast then or is he ordering right here?
Uh,
yeah.
Jeans.
Can I a
double pipe.
Classic
Double Decker Taco.
No jeans.
That'll be it.
All right.
Loving money.
Hilarious.
So good guys.
That was Jordan.
What do you mommy?
Nice jeans.
That was really good.
Yeah,
they get better and better,
man.
We played some at the live show.
Oh my God.
Were unreal.
We'll have to play some of those again.
That girl had a really,
holy shit.
Killer one,
Huh?
Bobby?
How can I help you?
How can you give me a moment?
I'm just glassing so a problem.
Take your time.
You realize too that the funny thing about that expression,
yeah.
Is that one really nobody needs explanation.
Yeah.
It kind of is intuitive.
It's intuitive.
Yeah.
You're like just glass and,
Oh,
you're,
you're looking.
Yeah.
And then,
and I feel like,
I feel like we helped introduce us the word into the lexicon.
We did we,
yeah,
we did.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It existed but existed.
But I feel like we've given it a push.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
A White Mocha 20 outs.
They're like that hotter.
Cool.
Um,
let's do it ice and also let me get a bottled water.
I got to stay hydrated.
Okay.
And would you like the head table with that with wet please?
Would you like BD water or regular three or five regular water's fine.
Is that all for you?
Yep,
that'll be all high pull around.
[inaudible] Alrighty.
Thanks jeans.
That's fantastic.
That's Louie.
I liked it.
The Guy Laugh.
Yeah,
of course.
Because it's so,
it's such nonsense that someone tells you I got to stay hydrated to,
yeah.
I imagine on if you're on the other and the receiving end of that ordering
though.
Yeah.
That you probably can't hear a lot of what people say.
Oh,
right.
Part of what people.
Okay.
Yeah.
Now,
if you want to up your,
hey mommy,
thanks genes game.
Yeah.
If you do it face to face with a waitress,
which you do.
Yeah,
that's I'd say a hundred bonus points face to face.
Yeah.
But the caveat being you can't do it to a native English speaker.
You've got to do it to somebody who English is a second language and not a very
good one at the point.
Well you can't at the moment.
You can do things when they're like,
hey,
we just got a table right here for you guys.
You Go,
thanks James.
Thanks James.
Yeah.
And then they're like,
hey,
I enjoy your meal.
Like they don't pick up on it there.
If you're looking straight at him and be like,
hey mommy.
I mean,
that might be different,
but you've done it to our Asian waitresses.
I think you did it last night.
And we were eating Sushi,
you said,
thanks genes alive.
Yeah.
And then my favorite is when you're always like,
thanks gorgeous.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
So how can you bring me that?
The Chub,
you get a chance.
Beautiful that they're like,
okay,
we did some shitty white guy.
I know I got a not another Ali's ease or songs and love it.
So,
um,
it's just like the gaze.
It's just like the case.
Thank you guys for listening.
Hopefully I'll get this fucking computer fixed.
Weird.
Have you tried restarting it?
What does it cost you?
Money to fix it better.
Not cost more than a hundred dollars.
No,
I know the rules.
All right.
Uh,
can be tried.
Restarting it.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Don't forget Tom,
cigarette dotcom and thousand ranch.com.
Yeah,
that's deep bro.
Podcast tee shirt at Tom [inaudible] dot com and the shop a store.
You Go,
you get the,
get the newest deep bro Shirt.
Please shout through our Amazon banners and um,
we'll see you in a week.
Good genes.
Bye Mommy.
I mommies will love you.
Team G.
It's just like the gate to gate to gate.
Hey.
Yeah.
You like uncircumcised surgery?
Yes,
I would.
It just like the game.
Yeah.
Yes,
I was.